[Música]
y efectivamente nos trasladamos a Ciudad
de México con nuestro corresponsable a
Mario carbonell el tema de esta noche
son las denuncias de Los Defensores de
la libertad de prensa que aseguran que
el gobierno o el ejército mantienen
prácticas de espionaje contra Defensores
de los Derechos Humanos María Un saludo
para usted y En qué consisten estas
denuncias que citan el uso del Software
Israel y pegasus
Hola Así es son tres organizaciones las
que anunciaron que presentarán una
denuncia ante la fiscalía general de la
república se trata de artículo 19 la red
en defensa de los Derechos digitales y
amnistía internacional que denuncian
precisamente este espionaje por parte
del ejército contra dos periodistas
Ricardo Rafael uno más del portal animal
político cuyo nombre se mantiene en
reserva así como un defensor de Derechos
Humanos Raymundo Ramos en Tamaulipas
señalaron que están conscientes de que
es muy probable que no avancen estas
investigaciones en la fiscalía pues ya
llevan más de cinco años que presentaron
otras denuncias por espionaje con
pegasus correspondientes al sexenio de
Peña Nieto y no hay aún Claridad al
respecto señaló por ejemplo Daniel
Moreno el director del portal animal
político que la infiltración al celular
de uno de sus reporteros no nada más lo
afecta a él sino que da vulneró toda la
redacción y pues tiene ahí las bases de
datos y toda la información que venían
trabajando Raymundo Ramos el defensor de
Derechos Humanos lamentó que el gobierno
se dedique a investigar a activistas y
no a los criminales a los que debería
estar siguiéndoles la pista
señalaron Esto bueno también Ricardo
Rafael uno de los aludidos o uno de los
de las víctimas
lamentó que no nada más es él sino
también su hijo menor de 12 años quien
Pues fue víctima de este espionaje con
pegasus ya comprobado con el citizenlab
con sede en Toronto Mario y señalan al
gobierno o al ejército que en términos
prácticos podría ser de la misma fuente
y eso a pesar de que en 2018 Andrés
Manuel López Obrador prometió que este
espionaje terminaría
es correcto desde que asumió el gobierno
y en reiteradas ocasiones de manera
posterior ha señalado el presidente que
en su gobierno ya no existían esas
prácticas que incluso él fue víctima de
espionaje con pegasos y que por una
cuestión de principios su gobierno ya no
realizaba esta esta labor de espionaje
que incluso por eso se ha desmantelado
el centro de investigación y seguridad
nacional el cisén que durante décadas se
dedicó precisamente al espionaje
político no obstante bueno los
activistas que hoy presentaron esta
denuncia señalan que como está aprobado
que fue el ejército hay dos opciones o
que el presidente no dijo la verdad no
habló con la verdad al referir que ya no
se llevaba a cabo la práctica de
espionaje o bien que las fuerzas armadas
actuaron a espaldas del mandatario y
comandante supremo precisamente de las
fuerzas armadas lo cual Pues en
cualquiera de los dos escenarios es una
situación grave que pone en riesgo no
solamente realmente la libertad de
expresión sino la integridad misma de
los activistas también mencionar que el
centro de Derechos Humanos Miguel
Agustín Pro Juárez pues después de lo
revelado por los guacamayas dijeron que
están siendo Víctimas de precisamente
ser considerados como un grupo de golpe